I've got an instant classic for you this
is Sean Spicer the White House yesterday
walked back basically the key point of
Donald Trump's unsubstantiated
allegation about President Obama
wiretapping his phones and Trump Tower
during the 2016 election White House
press secretary Sean Spicer said
yesterday well when Trump tweeted about
wiretapping multiple times he wasn't
actually talking about wiretapping a spy
sir gave one of these gong show press
briefings yesterday where he said
wiretapping doesn't mean wiretapping
because wiretapping was in quotes here's
clip number one the president used the
word wiretapping quote to mean broadly
surveillance and other activities and
again here is clip number two I just go
back to me you just said a minute ago
that you know what the president cement
when he tweeted about the wire kevin was
and you serve explained it but you've
also suited that podium into the tweet
speaks for itself when you decide when a
president tweets when his words are open
to interpretation and when those words
stand on her own I in turn I mean I'm
sorry can you further explain what
you're at I mean his tweets do speak for
themselves you just sort of interpreted
it for Peters and well he didn't mean at
president not like that no no actually
they when he when he said when he met
wired happened right at it he meant
surveillance literally had it in quotes
so you're interpreting to tweet forth
know in some cases all asked him what
did the quotes mean and they'll say I
did what anything he said they were in
quotes it was referring to surveillance
overall Trump was very explicit and
literal about this saying terrible just
found out that Obama had my wires
captain Trump Tower just before the
victory nothing found this is
McCarthyism then tweeting is it legal
for a sitting president to be
wiretapping a race for president prior
to an election turned down by court
earlier a new low and tweeting how low
has President Obama gone to tap my phone
during the very sacred election process
this is Nixon Watergate bad or sick guy
wiretapping is not some broad term used
to refer to surveillance overall a spy
sir is saying the merriam-webster
dictionary has two definitions to
tap a telephone or Telegraph wire in
order to get information and number two
to tap the telephone of so even if
wiretapping somehow meant general
surveillance it would still mean that
Donald Trump is claiming President Obama
had surveillance on him during 2016 and
we're back to where we started that is a
claim made with no evidence hopefully
media won't focus on this too much and
they'll report on the other insane more
important things that are going on in
Washington as we do on this program
because this yet again seems like a way
for Donald Trump to obfuscate other
things that are going on hey look over
there wiretapping but it's still really
important to touch on the reality that
the President of the United States is
tweeting groundbreaking claims what
would be groundbreaking realities if
they were true with really consequential
implications without presenting any
evidence he makes the claim and tells
other government officials go and figure
it out and obviously they can't figure
it out because it appears to not be real
and the most important point is if it's
real if indeed Donald Trump was
wiretapped by the Justice Department
under Barack Obama that's really bad for
Trump because it would indicate that he
was suspected of doing really serious
things most of which would be crimes
send me your thoughts about this out on
Twitter at d pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show